j'avais dit voilà molière vous avez
découvert que j'ai dit que quand j'étais
au lit au collège et qu'on étudie
molière et bien que je trouvais ça
chiant d'accord eh bien figurez vous
qu'à une personne qui n'a pas du tout
digéré vos propos bahia n'a pas que je
crois c'est eric eric poquelin qui est
le directeur artistique du théâtre
lorette dans le 10ème arrondissement de
paris elle qu'il te pas et qu'elle
surtout le dernier descendant de jean
baptiste poquelin alias molière on a la
chance de l'avoir avec nous ce soir
il va pas m'embrouiller j'aime pas les
embrouilles membres se sont mis d'accord
à nature pas tilté assurent qu'ils
s'étaient s'est pris un dernier
descendant de molière eric poquelin elle
a compris le
populaire c'est mieux
eric merci d'être avec nous est un des
derniers descendants de jean baptiste
poquelin dit molière tout à fait
l'arrière arrière arrière arrière
arrière petit fils de jean baptiste
poquelin vous avec china la faisons ce
soir face à ce que vous avez été choqué
par ses propos j'ai été extrêmement
choqué par ses propos d'ailleurs je
voulait rétablir un petit peu l'eau
propre qui a été jeté sur bon c'était
pas méchant mais c'était quand même
indicatifs et s'était spontanément dit
un petit peu vindicatif je pense ya
beaucoup de beaux lots
propos rétablir la vérité sur molière
qu'est ce qui vous plaît pas sûr alors
maintenant mais c'est vrai que quand
j'étais en troisième et en quatrième et
qu on it should i du molière déjà pour
moi le théâtre ça se regarde et ça ne se
lit pas nous quand on est au collège et
au lycée on lit du monde hier on nous
fait de dire du molière et la manière
dont je l'aï appris j'ai trouvé ça
change et voilà et parce que j'étais
après j'ai pas eu cette éducation la des
pièces littéraire judo d'éducation comme
j'adore moda rejet dans une toute petite
j'ai dans ce jeu
c'est vrai que des pièces classiques
j'adorerais en jouer parce que je trouve
ça magnifique mais il faut il faut il
faut y aller il faut s'y mettre oui
c'est vrai mais après c'est vrai que
j'ai pas en tout cas je trouvais ça et
tout va nous préférer le chien le couple
excusez moi vous reconnaissez vous voir
quand même que c'est un des plus grands
dramaturges et auteur contemporain si
j'avais à l'époque à mais évidemment
mais alors dire voilà eric la rai tu as
raison pour laquelle vous êtes ici ce
soir oui c'est que vous pratiquez
également le spiritisme et tous est
arrivé a également spiritisme et sa
place à s'ouvrir comme ça mais je pense
arriver qu'avec l'esprit de votre
arrière-arrière-arrière à rien géant
régulièrement avec lui effectivement il
ya celle à comprendre mais on le fait ou
a effectivement cette fréquence alors
est ce que vous pouvez ce qu'on pensait
que ce serait possible d'entrer en
contact avec molière pour qu'il parle à
capteur s'appelait ont tout essayé bien
sûr oui bien sûr les silences mais si on
me laissait un peu de cannelle de
silence sur bercy
chery hawtai la chance quand même gênant
mais ça me touche de fard sur molière va
me falloir sait pas encore sur un an
mais je vous dis sincèrement mollir est
entré en moi quand même enfin il est
vraiment dans mon corps on veut pas
savoir quand même pas tout mais vous dit
certaines choses quand même alors allez
vous l'écrivez
je lui ai écrit me répond je ressens les
choses et vous versez moyen c'est de
voir ça en dix ans
les jardins d'arlette arlette c'est la
famille c'est aller allons-y je suis au
p c'est un descendant de mollets oui aux
braves
gens n'hésitent pas à baptiste poquelin
jean baptiste poquelin eric poquelin
d'accord et je me dire c'est que jean
boiteux jb oui on pourra faire pareil
avec sim après on va
peut-être avoir une vie en fait il
s'avère qu'il est très choquée par vos
propos et très blessé je ressens c'est
en moi et il m'a dit que vos propos le
chagriner c'était quelque chose qui ne
l'apprécié pas du tout du tout du tout
mais c'est ça hyper flatté que molière
soit suisse était choquée de mes propos
ça veut dire qu'il a alors je vais quand
même le rajouter sur la feuille de
service pour dit il est surtout blessé
ça lui plaît pas dire qu'ils vont
lire koné capucine adam il la connaît
ooyala l'intermédiaire de moi même temps
mes dires est d'accord villa lui dire
regarde ces quatre story
elle a participé encore ce n'est pas
dans ses dirigeants qui voient les
choses mais alors qu'est ce qui va lui
dire molière ce soir ils aimeraient
molière que capucine s'excuse
publiquement devant tout le monde ah
qu'elles reconnaissent pas ces propos un
petit peu déplacé non d'après n'a le
droit de dire ce qu'elle veut je
retranscris je retransmets ce qu'il dit
voilà les dents longues mais y'a aucun
problème parce qu est ce qu elle a dit
parce que depuis le début moi je suis un
geek manière c'était chiant quand j'ai
emballé non été trop loin la vague
je sais que tous ceux qui parlent et
francis huster d'ailleurs je m'en
tamponne de monsieur francis huster deux
comme s'ils étaient seuls
dix fois la comédie française
je suis fou de francis huster je l'adoré
c'est le meilleur pour moi c'est le
meilleur il a été il a pris votre
dépense en avait la classe et la classe
savoyards aux tirs c'est la classe non
mais ma bulle rose et c'est là que vous
connaissez le tartuffe il a fait le
malade imaginaire et j'en passe et des
meilleurs
il faut s'intéresser à son heure avant
qu'il
soit malade imaginaire il ya alors
qu'est ce que c'est tout ce qu'il a pu
dire pour l'instant c'est tout ce qu'il
a lu dire puisqu'elle n'a pas reconnu
publiquement qu'elles voulaient que les
états
excusez moi monsieur molière mais ces
voleurs la regarde pas en l'air vers la
caméra est en baisse et du ballon parce
qu'il ya le regard d'un
bond il voulait lui dire aussi que
capucine comme chez une copine
de finesse
avec ça est ce que vous pouvez faire
capuche
exceptionnel c'est ça qui va venir ouais
ouais mais en gros c'est ça si on
traduit un peu tout ça c'est bien là il
écrit mieux
[Rires]
merci merci en tout cas merci bonsoir
voila ça s'arrange et je pense qu'on a
colmaté un petit peu les mains très bien
merci eric merci eric poker
[Applaudissements]